(upbeat music)
There's no place like home.
And that's why we're celebrating
as many hometowns as we can.
All across the country, all season long.
Next up is Portland, Oregon
where culinary professional, Judiaann Woo calls home.
I hear she makes it her mission
to know all the best restaurants and chefs in town.
Now that's a woman after my own heart.
Let's watch.
Hey, Drew, it is Kara Mack,
host of KATU's "Afternoon Live",
your sibling show in Portland, Oregon
and I know you're celebrating hometown spirit.
Well, no one has more hometown spirit
than our very own Judiaann Woo.
Judiaann, share with people why Portland's so awesome.
Portland is my hometown and I love it so much.
There were so many amazing places to eat and drink.
Plus scenic beauty and the most passionate
and creative people you will ever meet.
And you're gonna show it off for everyone.
So we're gonna send you off, have so much fun.
(upbeat music)
Welcome to OMSI.
OMSI stands for the Oregon Museum of Science and Industry.
It's got something for everybody.
You learn about the earth, the universe,
and everything in between.
We have here giant Australian walking sticks.
This is one corner of the museum
where they have actual live creatures
that you can interact with such as these.
Say hello to Drew.
I'm here at Toki restaurant
in the heart of downtown Portland
and behind me is chef-owner, Peter Cho.
He's doing his take on the most delicious,
crave-worthy Korean American classics.
This is like, you know, portable food.
So good.
Yes.
Portland is also known as The Rose City
and what better place to wrap up our tour
than the International Rose Test Gardens.
Here on the grounds,
we have 10,000 different bushes representing
over 610 varieties of roses
in every single color imaginable.
It's the ultimate place to find your zen.
Well Drew, that was just a quick peek at Portland,
the city we love so much.
We can't wait for you to come visit.
See ya soon.
Thanks, Judiaann.
I remember going to Naomi Pomeroy's restaurant, Beast,
and we hung out all night long.
One of the great nights of my life.
We're definitely hanging out the next time I'm in Portland.
See you soon.
(upbeat music)